JAY HARMON: As an
entrepreneur, you
have the chance to turn your
vision into a product people
love.
Putting your ideas
in front of users
is a great way to
learn what people like
and what could use some work.
The quicker you build,
the faster you learn.
And prototyping is the best
way to iterate and refine
your ideas.
In Rapid Prototyping
by Google and Udacity,
you'll build fast, code list
prototypes using InVision,
test with real users, and
get feedback on your ideas.
You'll use that feedback to make
quick and insightful iterations
to your design and move
forward with confidence.
You'll test with users
across the globe in realtime
and use their
qualitative feedback
to hone in on a better design.
Dream, build, and iterate.
Get to work building
your idea today.
Visit udacity.com/google.